buffers consists of a significant amount
of a weak acid which we will represent
as h a
and the conjugate base to the weak acid
which we will represent as a minus
buffer solutions resist large changes in
ph however buffers are only effective
over a certain range of ph values
we are going to use the
henderson-hasselbalch equation to find
the effective ph range of a buffer
looking at the henderson-hasselbalch
equation the ph of the buffer solution
is equal to the pka of the weak acid
which would be h a plus the log of the
concentration of the conjugate base
divided by the concentration of the weak
acid and it's this ratio of the
concentration of the conjugate base to
the concentration of the weak acid that
determines if a buffer is effective or
not
buffer solutions are most effective at
resisting a change in ph in either
direction when the concentration of the
weak acid is equal to the concentration
of the conjugate base and when the
concentrations are equal to each other
the ratio is equal to 1 and the log of 1
is equal to
zero
therefore when the concentrations are
equal to each other the ph of the buffer
solution is equal to the pka of the weak
acid plus zero so we could just say that
the ph is equal to the pka when the
concentration of the weak acid is equal
to the concentration of the conjugate
base
so we usually try to choose a buffer
with a weak acid that has a pka value
close to the desired ph of the solution
so buffers are effective at resisting
large changes in ph when the ph is
approximately equal to the pka of the
weak acid however if the concentration
of one component of a buffer is more
than 10 times the concentration of the
other component in a buffer buffers are
not effective at resisting large changes
to ph
therefore to find the effective ph range
we're going to use the
henderson-hasselbalch equation to
calculate the ph when the concentration
of the conjugate base is 10 times the
concentration of the weak acid and also
to calculate the ph when the
concentration of the weak acid is 10
times the concentration of the conjugate
base
doing these two calculations gives us
the upper and lower limits of the
effective ph range
so let's calculate the ph of the buffer
solution when the concentration of the
conjugate base is 10 times the
concentration of the weak acid looking
at the henderson-hasselbalch equation if
the concentration of the conjugate base
is 10 times the concentration of the
weak acid the ratio is equal to 10 over
1
and the log of 10 is equal to 1.
therefore the ph of the buffer solution
is equal to the pka value of the weak
acid plus one this value for the ph
represents the upper limit of the
effective ph range
next let's calculate the ph of the
buffer solution when the concentration
of weak acid is 10 times the
concentration of the conjugate base
looking at the henderson-hasselbalch
equation if the concentration of h a is
10 times the concentration of a minus
the ratio is equal to 1 over 10 and the
log of 1 over ten is equal to negative
one therefore the ph of the buffer
solution is equal to the pka value of
the weak acid minus one this value for
the ph represents the lower limit of the
effective ph range
by the calculations that we've just done
we've seen that the effective ph range
of a buffer is plus or minus 1 of the
pka value of the weak acid let's use
this concept of an effective ph range to
choose a buffer solution let's say we
want to buffer a solution at a ph of
9.00
at 25 degrees celsius and suppose that
we have two choices we could either
choose an acetic acid acetate buffer or
we could choose an ammonium ammonia
buffer because the effective ph range of
a buffer is plus or minus 1 the pka
value of the weak acid we don't want to
choose the acetic acid acetate buffer
solution because at 25 degrees celsius
the pka value for acetic acid is equal
to 4.74
therefore this buffer would only be
effective at a range of plus or minus 1
from 4.74
so about 3.74 to approximately 5.74
the ammonium cation has a pka value
equal to 9.25
at 25 degrees celsius therefore the
ammonium ammonia buffer is effective
plus or minus 1 of this pka value so
approximately
8.25 to 10.25
since our ph of 9 falls within that
range we would choose the ammonium
ammonia buffer